retour en france avec le début des
hommages à samuel pâtissier à la veille
de la date anniversaire de l'assassinât
de l'enseignant tué pour avoir montré
des caricatures du prophète mahomet en
classe tous les établissements scolaires
de france sont invités à se recueillir
sous différentes formes aujourd'hui une
journée de commémoration est dommage qui
doit commencer à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines là où enseigne et samuel pâtit
les détails avec notre reporter natacha
terrain sic
d'abord une minute de silence devrait
être tenu dans tous les établissements
scolaires dans les écoles les collèges
et les lycées les éventuelles
perturbations seront sanctionnés s'ils a
fait savoir jean michel blanquer le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
gabriella talent le porte-parole du
gouvernement a fait savoir cette semaine
qu'il y aurait une heure de cours en
hommage à la mémoire de samuel paty et
autour des thématiques assez complexe de
la liberté d'expression du vivre
ensemble ou encore de la laïcité dans
l'espace public un hommage spécial est
prévu demain à 14 heures ici même dans
le collège donne ou samuel pâtit
enseignait professeurs et membres du
personnel scolaire devrait prendre la
parole en présence d'élèves de parents
d'élèves et de jean michel blanquer à
eragny sur oise commune limitrophe de
conflans sainte honorine où habitait
samuel apathie une autre cérémonie est
prévue demain une fresque dommage
réalisée par un artiste graffeur de la
ville devrait être dévoilé à cette
occasion jean michel blanquer requis
devrait aussi dévoiler demain une plaque
en hommage au professeur dans le hall
d'honneur de son ministère rue de
grenelle à paris seront présents la
famille de samuel pâtit différents
représentants du ministère de l'académie
de versailles
plusieurs représentants d'organisations
syndicales et des associations de
parents d'élèves la famille de samuel
pâtit qui devrait aussi être reçu demain
par
emmanuel macron le président de la
république et jean castex le premier
ministre à l'elysée voilà pour
l'essentiel des hommages heures rendue
aujourd'hui et demain un an après
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit ce
professeur d'histoire géographie de 47
ans assassinée par un élève tchétchène
de 18 ans qui reprochaient au professeur
d'avoir montré des caricatures du
prophète mahomet en classe